♪ OOOOOHHHHHH
DO IT ♪
HI, EVERYBODY,
I'M LYLE,
STANDING IN NEW YORK CITY,
BOOB CAPITAL
OF NORTH AMERICA,
LOOKING FOR GREAT NEW YORK
BOOBS.
♪ DO THE HUSTLE ♪
'SCUSE ME,
PARDON ME, MISS.
HI, CAN I TALK TO YOU
FOR ONE SECOND ?
PARDON ME, CAN I TALK
TO YOU FOR MY T-V SHOW ?
PLEASE, DON'T RUN.
BOY, SHE HAD SOME SWEET
NEW YORK BOOBS.
HI, GUYS, I'M LYLE, AND YOU
HAVE GREAT NEW YORK BOOBS.
OH, MY GOD !
HI, WHAT'S YOUR NAME ?
JEANNIE.
JEANNIE ?
YOU HAVE GREAT
NEW YORK BOOBS.
OH !
FANTASTIC.
♪ DO THE HUSTLE ♪
THIS IS JOE ROGAN
FROM N-B-C's FEAR FACTOR.
HELLO, LADIES.
HELLO.
CAN I TELL
YOU SOMETHING ?
WHAT ?
YOU HAVE GREAT
NEW YORK BOOBS.
ARE WE TALKING
"C" CUPS ?
"D" CUPS, PERHAPS ?
YES, "C",
"C" CUPS.
WELL, I'D DRINK FROM
THOSE "C" CUPS ANY DAY.
FABULOUS.
THEY REST ON MY ARM
LIKE AN EAGLE ON A PERCH.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE BEST BOOBS
YOU CAN SEE IN THE CITY.
BR-BR-BR-BROMSKY.
PLEASE, DON'T RUN,
THEY'RE BUSY.
♪ DO THE HUSTLE ♪
AND THIS IS JOE ROGAN
FROM N-B-C's FEAR FACTOR.
CAN I TELL YOU
SOMETHING ?
YES.
YOU HAVE GREAT
NEW YORK BOOBS.
THANKS...
FABULOUS.
THAT'S MY DAD,
MAN.
WELL, SIR...
YOU HAVE
FABULOUS GENETICS.
THAT'S ALL I CAN TELL YOU
BECAUSE YOU HELPED MAKE A GREAT
SET OF NEW YORK BOOBS.
MAN, WHAT
THE (BLEEP) IS THIS ?